good evening i'm councillor simon wooden
leader of rochford district council i'm
pleased to open this virtual webinar
public engagement session
which will focus predominantly on the
radio site's pre-application part
of the council's asset delivery program
i would like to extend a warm welcome to
members of the public
who have given their time to join us
this evening
although it feels very different to a
physical meeting
we have become used to working virtually
over many months
so in the circumstances this is the best
medium possible
i stress however that this is only part
of the engagement process
with members of the community
i am pleased to introduce mike davis
chairman of
radytown museum management group who
will be chairing this evening's meeting
i'm really grateful to him for giving up
his time and the interest he is showing
in the council's asset delivery program
mike is a long-standing and very
well-respected resident
within this district and he is
passionate about the community
and heritage across the district but
particularly in rayleigh
i am delighted that so many people have
joined the webinar
as well as taking questions later in the
presentations
you are invited to ask questions during
the webinar
using the web chat facility
at long last it is a pleasure to be able
to discuss the proposals in more detail
and invite you to share in the vision i
want to emphasize however
that contrary to what i have seen
reported in various places
these are just proposals at present
nothing is set in stone so feedback
is not just welcomed but vital to help
shape
what the final scheme will look like
both in rayleigh
and in rockford we want to hear what
people think
the meeting will be recorded and shared
for those
who are unable to attend at this point
i will hand over to mike davis mike over
to you
my thanks to councillor simon wooden the
leader of rocha district council for
that most
generous introduction we have a number
of presentations this evening
in this the second of two such webinars
relating to the six sites across
rochford
as part of the rocha district council
asset
delivery program tonight we are going to
deal specifically with the rayleigh
plans
although it is important to note that
all six sites to include the three in
rochard
are part of the overall package and the
panel are happy to deal with
the overview as may be required
thank you for agreeing to take part in
our live webinar
nearly 200 people have registered to
attend
and we have received to date over 140
questions
to include those relating to our
heritage the mount the new community
centre the environment
covid financials transport
and many more and everyone's
contribution
comments and opinions are very much
valued
everyone's concerns will be addressed
the question and answer session will
last in the region of one hour
and in order to deal with as many
questions as possible
i ask that both questions and answers be
as brief as possible
so we can try and cover as many
different issues as we possibly can
indeed some responses may have a more
detailed explanation on the rocha
district council
voyage partnership website by the end of
the week
please be aware that you may appear on
camera and be heard on microphone
by everyone accessing this presentation
this webinar will be recorded and by
participating
you consent to being part of that
recording
which as with the rocha presentation
will be available on the rochefort
district council website
the aim is to help maximize involvement
by as many members of the public as
possible
ahead of the formal planning application
especially for those not able to be with
us this evening
please note that all participants must
act in a respectful and courteous manner
to allow a productive session where all
will have the opportunity to listen to
the presentations
to take part in the question and answer
session and
to make their opinions heard should
there be any continuous disruption
or discourteous behavior which i'm
certainly do not expect from rainey
residents
i as chairman reserve the right to ask
the person to desist
and removal from the meeting as a last
resort
questions will be displayed on screen so
that everyone
attending the webinar can see the detail
of what is being asked
and then i will either call you to read
out your question or where requested
i will read out the question myself and
pass on to a panelist
it may be that more than one member of
the panel will answer different aspects
of a particular question
there is also a facility and a possible
opportunity
for you to ask a question during the
session on the chat line
which we may be able to answer during
the evening
especially if it relates to a subject
that has not already been raised
or dealt with during the presentations
as we have received some 140 plus
questions
although some are duplicated it is just
not possible
to give a full answer to everyone this
evening however
as with the rochford presentation all
questions together with the responses
will be available on the rocha district
council voyage partnership website
within a few days i thank you for your
full cooperation which is greatly
appreciated
it is planned that this presentation
will take in the region
of one and a half to two hours i will
now
introduce the panel who will be
presenting the detailed
uh presentations first we have angela
hutchins
angela is the acting managing director
for the rochford district council
matt harwood white is the assistant
director for assets and commercial
for rochford district council and the
senior officer responsible
for this asset delivery program
george farley is from gb partnerships
and is the program director for the
voyage program
gb partnership of the private sector
delivery
partner selected by rdc under a
competitive tendering process
to lead on the voyage program gb
specialise in public sector partnerships
and development programs
we then have peter buist peter is from
purcell architects
and is the lead architect for the
program
angela will now speak on the background
to this asset delivery program
the project to date how you can
contribute with your views
ahead of the final plans to include have
your say
and the website details and how all six
sites dovetail into the overall plan
i'll now pass you over to angela
thank you very much mike good evening
everybody
many people have asked how and why we've
come to this particular set of proposals
so i think it's worth explaining that in
some detail
offices and i first began this
conversation when we were discussing
what to do with the two event sites
which were at the time
part of the leisure's council's leisure
contract with fusion lifestyle
we already knew that event sites were
becoming a financial problem for
councils
20 years ago when the leisure contract
was let they were the mainstay of
weddings
parties and entertainment but over the
last two decades that market has changed
and with more venues available for
public hire
and with better facilities both the
freight house and the mill hall were
looking pretty tired and were becoming
uneconomic to run that made us then look
at the rest of the council's real estate
the civic suite israeli and the
council's offices in rochford
and we noticed a number of recurring
themes
firstly they were all aging buildings
which were in need of significant
updating
not just in terms of bricks and mortar
but also in terms of electrics mechanics
and technology to bring them up to
modern standards like broadband wi-fi
projection equipment etc they were
expensive to heat
light operate and maintain and they had
limited opportunities to go green
we also noticed that they were heritage
sites which limited the scope for
widespread updating and they didn't work
particularly well as modern spaces for
example the porter cabin reception at
south street is cramped and unwelcoming
and the great eastern room at freight
house has poor acoustics
finally we noticed that the spaces were
underutilized for their size and that
didn't mean that they were necessarily
not well used but they were the wrong
size for most of their users
there were singular desk spaces that
were needed at south street and
more but not enough meeting room spaces
or collaborative spaces
and the fixed furniture of the council
chamber is so restrictive that it's
virtually impossible to use that space
for anything other than council meetings
and at other times
it says it sat empty we also noted that
the hireable space at freight house and
mill hall was limited
and often too big or too small for many
ordinary events
and so booking capacity was limited and
the commercial model was
uneconomic we knew
all council we would need to be smart to
find the money to upgrade these
buildings
as a council we have no borrowing and
nor do we have savings which could be
spent without a strong business case to
justify the investment
so we had an idea that if we could draw
out the value of our sites we might be
able to use that to fund the
regeneration
with little or no additional cash
contribution
but we're not experts in regeneration
and we wanted to test our thinking with
those who
are so we employed external professional
technical support
to stress test our idea to see if it
could work through developing what is
known as a strategic business case
in line with best practice government
treasury principles
the conclusion was that the idea could
work
it was possible to optimize the value of
the sick sites to generate enough value
to upgrade the council's civic office
and community spaces
and make the project overall broadly
crossed neutral
so the council decided to explore this
concept further
and with external professional technical
support we took the idea to the next
stage
to consider various options that could
deliver the outcomes of that upgraded
civic office and community space
and cost neutrality that piece of work
was the outline business case which was
again completed in line with best
practice government treasury principles
the option analysis in the outline
business case indicated that doing the
minimum i.e just
backlogged maintenance and ongoing
operation of the sick sites as they are
was more expensive in the longer term
than regeneration of them
the outline business case considered the
most likely options to reconfigure all
six sites
and achieve cost neutrality it wasn't an
exhaustive site-by-site analysis
it was a desktop study of how we could
leverage the best value for money
out of each site whilst regenerating
every single one
and putting in the least amount of
additional cash possible
and we decided to approach this project
as a programme solution
because we wanted every single one of
those six sites regenerated
we didn't want any of them to be left
behind we didn't want any of them to be
treated more preferentially than the
other
we didn't want any site to be neglected
so anyway an outline business case is
still a desktop analysis of the art of
the possible and you need to engage with
the market
to validate your workings you need
construction experts to do surveys and
drawings
and to tell you if what you think you
can be can be done is actually doable at
the cost that you think it can be done
so we undertook a competitive tendering
process to bring in a development
partner to do this work for us
we didn't tell them what we wanted them
to build we shared the outline business
case but the brief that they were given
was to deliver a solution
for upgraded civic office and community
spaces
achieving as near cost neutrality as
possible
across all six sites
we gave them something called an output
specification which details what
functionality we required so what we
needed the office
civic and community spaces to
accommodate in terms of people and
and abuses but we left it to the experts
to tell us the best way to achieve it
at the end of the tender process gb
partnerships was appointed
and i think it's worth pointing out that
we decided to bring in a development
partner
to work with us because we wanted to
exert our influence over the
eventual design not just of the
buildings that we're going to retain
but also the residential developments we
didn't want to lose control
over the quality of the development and
we wanted to ensure that the
regeneration of our important town
center locations was exemplary
in terms of sustainable development we
wanted to show
other developers how it should be done
there has been a lot of information and
misinformation about the proposals for
the mill hall
and so first off i think it's worth
repeating that no decision has been
taken about the future of the existing
mill hall or indeed the rest of the site
what we have is a proposal as part of a
program for the regeneration of the site
but secondly it's also not accurate to
say that the mill hall is being
demolished and replaced with flats
the proposal is for the regeneration of
the whole
site of course we're mindful of the
heritage aspects
and we would know we won't do anything
which compromises that
in fact we actually want to improve it
by creating a better landscape around
the windmill
and improved access to the mount
at the moment the vista of the windmill
is the bins at the back of the mill hall
surrounded by a car park
the beacon and holocaust memorial are
placed on a small patch of green in the
middle of a road
the proposals will create a new scheme
which is environmentally exemplar
extraordinarily high quality and which
will regenerate this part of the high
street
elected members identified that they
wanted to wanted a new community centre
for rayleigh
and so indicated they prepared to invest
approximately
one and a half million pounds additional
spend into the program
to get something really special but it
was important that this should be a
community centre and not an events
center an event center is reliant on a
commercial operating model to fund it
and what we want to create is a center
for use by the community
with a not-for-profit ethos we are
proposing to create a space which would
maximize use by the community
and which would also occu house our
existing partners
ravs citizens advice and the oaks
counselling service
the council will also occupy facilities
at the new community center where
residents can come in and speak with
officers
and we're working with ethics police to
develop how they can use that site
too for public outreach initiatives as
well as private meetings
enabling members of the public to
interact with their local policing teams
questions have been asked about the car
parking at the mill hall site
and the proposals do mean a net loss of
21 public car parking spaces compared to
what is there currently
but that also means that 100 public car
parking spaces would remain available
across the existing bellingham lane and
mill hall car parks
and all the proposed residential
development will have its own private
car parking in line with current
planning policy
now we didn't decide to remove car
parking willy-nilly
we were very clear with um the
developers and the bidders during the
course of the procurement
that removal of public car parking
spaces could only be justified
if it derived additional value for the
um
for the relevant site and i hope that
when you see the designs later on and
you hear the descriptions given by peter
that you will agree with me that that
additional amenity value
from the car parking spaces is adds
to the overall aesthetic of the of the
design
questions have also been asked of me if
the council has worked out the cost of
refurbishing the existing meal hall
so as i've said the options we
considered were in the outline business
case
but as part of the competitive tendering
process
we asked the market to tell us the best
value for money solution for all
six sites taken together as a program
which would deliver the functionality
that we required in our civic office and
community spaces
no bidder in the competitive tendering
process suggested retention and
refurbishment of the existing
mill hall as part of the programme
solution in other
words refurbishment of the mill hall was
not the best value for money option in
the program
the detailed analysis that we've done
with gp partnerships tells us that a
building which accommodates at least 95
percent of the existing regular bookings
is the optimal size to deliver best
value for money
and that's why we've proposed it now
remember that no decision has been made
but we can infer that refurbishment will
cost more
than the one and a half million pounds
which is the council's estimated
net count cash contribution for the
proposed solution
we have a duty to use taxpayers money to
achieve best value for money
so that is why we've presented the
current proposals
before kofi we were working on a
solution which anticipated that the mill
hall could have remained open
until the new centre was ready in order
to ensure a smooth transition and
no closure unfortunately the impact of
covid on leisure and hospitality
changed all that and although we're
delighted that the mill hall is
continuing to report it perform an
important community function as a
council we face significant financial
deficit in keeping the building open
bringing forward the new building will
mitigate the impact but will still leave
a gap and that continues to be a problem
for us especially as we move towards
recovery
and we will need to continue to keep
that under review
we also need to work hard to support the
approximately five percent of bookings
for whom the new community centre
will be smaller than their current needs
and we're talking directly with those
users as part of our stakeholder forum
and will support them to find solutions
that work
and i would encourage anybody who finds
themselves falling into that category to
contact us
and to be part of our stakeholder forum
and help us
with their thoughts and and reflections
solutions that might work would include
using the outdoor space
or a marquee or maybe running the event
over a number of dates
and because the council will be
operating the new building as a
community center
rather than a commercial events venue it
won't be a first
come first served and the most lucrative
event takes priority
approach we know that the community
shows are popular
and we want them to continue so we will
work together to make sure that it is
economically
viable for them to operate the council
is not interested in making money
out of community uses we've spoken to
hirers who are skeptical about how it
could work
but i'm really grateful to them for
helping us to work through the details
whilst we're still at this proposal
stage
their feedback is vital to shape and
influence the development
the design and the space and it's not
just about agreeing the colour of the
carpet
we waited to get to this point because
gb partnerships has now done the
groundwork and
satisfied that what we are sharing with
you this evening
is doable it's always a balancing act to
decide when is the best time to share
information too soon and you risk the
proposals being too vague and then we
can't answer your questions
but we think that we've done enough
preparatory work now to show you the
proposals and to be able to speak about
them with enough detail
to answer all your questions
so working with gb partnerships we want
to create new council buildings which
are environmentally
and financially sustainable for the
future
that will maintain community facilities
in rochford and in rayleigh
that will maintain accommodation for our
partner organizations
that are true to our heritage settings
and that will create
21st century fit buildings with
state-of-the-art technology
a lot of work has gone to get into the
project that to this point
to enable us to share something with you
that is more than just conceptual
to provide you with sufficient detail to
ask questions
understand the proposals and offer
feedback but
no planning application has yet been
submitted
and no formal counsel has been taken to
proceed so when we say we're asking for
your feedback
to help shape the next stage of this
project we really mean it
thank you mike
thank you angela for that very detailed
presentation with an awful lot of
information and kind of just remind
everybody at this stage please that
if you want to reflect on some of the
things that angela said
it will be available because this
presentation is being recorded
and you can refresh your memory or look
at any particular
parts of detail that you may want to so
we now move on
to our next presentation which is peter
peter's presentation will give specific
details of the designs
the core principles and the importance
of our heritage
relating to each of the rayleigh sites
in what will be the longest presentation
of this evening
i'll pass you over to peter thank you
thank you mike um and good evening good
evening everybody
um cs my name's peter buist i'm an
architect from
purcell architects we're a practice of
architects master planners and heritage
consultants
and we specialize in working with
buildings and sites that have
conservation and heritage constraints
we've been working with gb partnerships
and rockford district council for a
number of months
analyzing and understanding their
existing sites and developing outline
proposals for their future
i'm presenting on behalf of a team of
consultants that have been engaged on
these projects
including specialists such as civil
structural
building service engineers heritage
consultants
tree specialists and ecologists
i will now provide an overview of the
work that we have undertaken to date
across the two sites in rayleigh
including the project objectives
the opportunities and constraints of
each site and the principles of our
concept designs
as angela has said the designs on both
sites are at an early stage of
development where we have established
outline concept proposals and so we're
in a good position to receive your
comments and explore the incorporation
of these into the designs as they
develop
i'll start with the civic suite site
first and then move on to the mill site
so with the relocation of council
functions to the new community centre at
the mill site
and freight house in rochford the
existing buildings at the civic suite
would no longer be used for delivering
council services
so our proposals for the civic suites
site are for a mixed use development
to provide both residential and
commercial accommodation
this will be achieved through the
retention restoration
and conversion of some of the existing
buildings on the site
as well as the construction of a new
residential building
the scheme proposals will support the
town centre of raleigh
by delivering ongoing employment on the
site
as well as sustainable town centre
dwellings that meet local housing needs
the scheme retains public car parking in
the market car park with a small
reduction
in capacity
the existing buildings at the civic
suite are concentrated towards the
northern end of the site
the image on the left shows the listed
building known as barrington's
from the junction of webster's way the
high street and hockley road
barrington's is an early 19th century
building of white brick
with traditional sash windows and a
projecting portico to the main entrance
built originally as a dwelling the
building has been converted to offices
and is currently occupied by btmk
solicitors
to the east of the listed building is a
1950s extension
that accommodates the council chamber at
brown's law and
office and meeting rooms above set
further back from hockley road and
extending further south is the 1964
extension
that accommodates council offices and
meeting spaces
the image on the right-hand side of the
slide is the current entrance to the
later 1960s block and the main entrance
to the council
so our understanding of the site and its
surroundings
helps us identify the opportunities and
the constraints that inform
our proposals to the north of the site
is the great two star listed holy
trinity church
and the site itself is located within
the rayleigh conservation area
we have therefore referred to the
council's conservation area appraisal
and are conscious of the impact of our
proposals
on these heritage assets
within the site is the grade two listed
barrington's building that i've already
described
whilst this is within the site the
proposals do not look to include any
alterations to this building
the site is bound on three sites by
hockley road webster's way
and bull lane each of which have their
own character
and scale of buildings to the north east
is the market car park
and to the south is king george's park
the site slopes down from the higher
level along hockley road to the lower
level of bull lane
much of the south of the site is car
parking set back from the pavement line
by grass verges and chain link fencing
there's an existing memorial tree
fronting onto a bull lane and the bus
shelter faces webster's way
the existing buildings on the site are
two-story but due to generous internal
ceiling heights and the sloping site
these represent the heights of
three-story buildings
the conservation area appraisal notes
that webster's way
lacks a defining la uh defining
streetscape
and car parking as identified as a
negative townscape feature
with the view of the site from webster's
way being identified as an opportunity
for enhancement
so our proposals focus on improving the
setting of the listed building
by removing the less sensitive 1960s
council administration block
and restoring and converting the 1950s
council chamber block
the proposals create a frontage onto
webster's way with a new residential
building
that provides a mix of one two and three
bedroom apartments
we recognize the importance of public
car parking to the vitality of the town
centre
and so the proposals retain 55 public
spaces at the market car pipe
the proposals also provide both car and
bicycle parking
and immediately space for residents and
employees
so this is the site plan of the current
sketch proposals with
north to the top of the slide the site
is accessed by the existing entrance
from hockley road
with the historic sweeping driveway
retained to the front of the listed
building
car parking for residents and employees
is provided along the eastern boundary
this car parking will be landscaped in a
softer way using finishes such as gravel
and tree and shrub planting between the
parking spaces
we've deliberately avoided locating new
buildings in this part of the site
to mitigate the impact on the existing
adjacent dwellings on bull lane
and highfield crescent the new
residential block is located fronting
webster's way
retaining the green space and trees to
the south of the listed building
and is set back from the pavement line a
new pedestrian access is provided to the
south
onto bull lane and opposite king
george's park
looking from the north along webster's
way the massing of the proposed new
residential block
steps down from four-story block to the
north
although the top floor is recessed back
down to two stories with dormer roofs uh
sorry dormer windows within the roof
to the south as it wraps around onto
bull
the building elevation is broken up into
distinct blocks
to reflect the historic plot widths that
are common within the conservation area
and to create a series of defined
frontages onto the street
so in summary the outline proposals
provide 25
one two and three bedroom apartments
with 35 of these dwellings being
affordable
the scheme includes nearly 300 square
meters of refurbished commercial office
space
on-site car parking is provided for
residents and employees with electric
vehicle charging points
secure bicycle and motorbike storage is
also provided
the new residential accommodation will
be designed and built
to a very good standard of energy
efficiency using high levels of thermal
insulation
to minimize energy use and using air
source heat pumps
for heating rather than fossil fuel
fired boilers
the scheme retains the listed building
and the adjoining council chamber block
and retains the mature and established
trees
to the north and west of the site as
well as the memorial tree to the south
new tree planting and soft landscaping
through the site
will improve the amenity and the ecology
so a short walk from the civic suite is
the mill arts and event event center
so i'll now talk through the outline
proposals for this site
our vision creates a mix of uses on the
site
that includes a new community centre and
a new residential development
arranged around a high quality and
accessible public space
that creates a visual and physical route
connecting the arrival to the site from
the high street
along bellingham lane with the historic
mill
to the north as with the civic suites
the proposals of the mill retain a
proportion of public car parking
that will support the town centre and
the new community centre
the car parking within the adjacent
bellingham lane car park
will be unaffected
again our understanding of the site both
historically and
in its current arrangement forms the
basis of our outline proposals
and we have referred to the detailed
assessment of the rayleigh mount
character area
in the conservation area appraisal
the mill hall as a building was
constructed in 1971
with alterations made in the late 1990s
it's a two-story flat roofed assembly
building that has an overall height
equivalent to a residential three-story
building
the site itself creates a transition
between the town
and the mount the open green space
located to the southern end
accommodates the beacon memorial and
bench seating
amongst mature trees and grass banks
while the entrance and frontage of the
mill hall addresses this green space
it has a sense of turning its back on
the historic mill
the conservation area appraisal notes
the lack of a sense of enclosure to the
site
views from the southern end of the site
through to the windmill are relatively
recent
having been opened up with the
demolition in 1998 of a large industrial
building
which was laterally used as a sports
hall and this may explain the current
lack of definition to the site
and the disjointed relationship between
the mill and the mill hall
the site largely provides public car
parking albeit carefully landscaped
with an enclosed sensory garden to the
north beyond the mill
it has a number of conservation and
heritage influences
the site accommodates the approach and
entrance to rayleigh mount
which is a scheduled ancient monument
and is an important area of parkland
accommodating mature trees and green
space
in fact the site itself occupies what
was the outer bailey of the mount
to the north end of the site is the 19th
century grade 2 listed windmill
and the site is in the rayleigh
conservation area
to the northeast and outside of the
outside of the site demise
is the historic terrace of 13 to 17
london hill
which is also grade 2 listed
the site slopes gradually down from the
north where the mill is located to the
south
and then drops further towards the west
and the dense belt of trees that
surround the mount
the surrounding context is mixed with
building heights varying between one and
four stories
and uses including commercial
residential and community functions
the open space in front of the mill hall
is enclosed on the north side
by the women's institute hall a long
rectangular building dating from 2000
but built in a traditional style
home regal house to the south of the
mill hall is a four-story residential
development
and the majority of former houses along
bellingham lane that back onto the site
have been converted to commercial office
use
the east side of bellingham lane
opposite the site is characterized by
servicing areas for retail and
commercial properties
and consequently the conservation area
appraisal
identifies the view north along
bellingham lane as negative
and an opportunity for enhancement
the sketch plan on the slide shows the
proposed master plan for the site
with north rotated to the right hand of
the slide
as i've explained the concept is to
create a high quality pedestrian
prioritized route through the site
to the east of this route so to the
bottom of the
the drawing is the new community centre
and public car parking
to the west which is to the top of the
drawing is the residential development
which consists of houses and apartments
with gardens and parking to the rear
the proposals include the demolition of
the existing mill arts and events centre
and its replacement with a modern
sustainable and flexible community
centre
that forms a better relationship with
the mill
this will create opportunities for the
two community assets to be used together
for public and private functions and
events
30 public car parking spaces will be
provided on
site next to the new community centre
the scheme enhances the existing
entrance to rayleigh mount
widening the approach and improving the
visibility and accessibility of the
parkland
the proposed housing provides a sense of
enclosure that has been identified in
the conservation area appraisal is
currently lacking
so this sketch shows the proposed
massing on the site and our initial
thoughts for the roof forms and
elevational treatments
we've drawn contemporary references from
the former industrial buildings that
were on the site and the wider
characteristics of the conservation area
the houses are located towards the
middle of the residential development
and the apartments are located at each
end
gardens and parking for residents
located to the rear
the new community center rises from
single story height
to two stories so that it remains
subservient to the historic mill
and preserves key views
as recommended by the conservation area
appraisal the vision is to create a
public
piazza and a unifying link that frames
the windmill
and draws people through the site
a view from the northern end shows the
proposed community centre
the main entrance to the community
centre faces the mill
with a new hard and soft landscaped
public realm between the two
the new centre is to be as
environmentally sustainable as possible
with a green roof living walls and solar
panels
and maximizing natural lighting and
ventilation where possible
again it will be heated through air
source heat pumps so there is no
reliance on fossil fuels
beyond is the proposed residential
development but is scaled to a similar
height as the existing mill hall
building
and home regal house to the south
so focusing on the new community center
the building provides
multi-purpose flexible spaces at ground
floor
supported by kitchen and catering
facilities
an entrance atrium that provides space
for exhibitions and breakout functions
gives independent access to each
multi-use space
and to the toilet facilities at first
floor
which is fully accessible by both lift
and stairs council office space and
accommodation for the citizens advice
ravs and oaks facilities are provided
the residential proposals deliver
approximately 32 new dwellings
which is a mix of one two and three
bedroom apartments and houses
thirty five percent of these drillings
again will be affordable
dedicated residential car motorcycle and
cycle parking is provided
which is separate from the retained
public car parking on the site
electric vehicle charging points will
also be provided
the project vision is to create a new
piece of public realm for rayleigh
that celebrates the windmill and
improves access to rayleigh mount
whilst delivering a new flexible
community center and local sustainable
housing
thank you and back to you mike
peter thank you for that very very
detailed presentation i think we need to
draw breath for a few minutes now after
putting in taking and all that
information but as i said the details
are available on the website and would
benefit from further
viewings um as part of this ongoing
process
it's now time for me to pass you over to
matt harwood white with his presentation
which will deal specifically with the
benefits of the asset delivery program
and the next steps in this process over
to you matt
thank you mike um good everyone um the
proposals will bring forward
modern sustainable and energy efficient
facilities
which represent the rich legacy of the
district
the proposed facilities will ensure the
retention of vital council services
within raleigh
from a new accessible and sustainable
community centre
that is flexible and efficient to run
and use
the community centre will include the
provision of purpose-built office
accommodation
for vital community services to be
delivered from
this will include provision for citizens
advice
radio rochefort and district association
voluntary services
and the adult counselling service
the council's proposals for development
have a strong focus on environmental
sustainability as peter has outlined
the proposal is for the new community
centre to be heated by an air source
heat pump system
which in itself is a renewable source of
energy and also typically costs less to
run
than a traditional heating system
together with roof mounted solar panels
the building is proposed to be
ventilated by mechanical heat and
ventilation recovery
to provide fresh filtered air whilst
retaining most of the energy
that has already been used in heating
the building
super insulated walls will also minimize
the amount of supplementary heating
required
the proposed design is peter is set out
incorporated green roof
in essence a layer of vegetation planted
over a waterproofing system
that is installed on top of the reef
structure as well as a green wall which
will be irrigated using grey water
that will ensure the green roof and wall
are low maintenance
the proposed new community centre will
save significant running costs
heating costs alone will be reduced by
approximately 65 percent
the size of the proposed new community
centre has understandably generated
feedback and many questions
the proposed media center is smaller
than the mill arts and event center
however our analysis shows over 95
percent of pre-coded bookings
can be accommodated by the proposed new
community center
for the remaining five percent of the
larger events
there are a number of ways in which
these can continue to be accommodated
and the council was talking directly
with those users to find ways to ensure
that they can continue to thrive in
railing
turning to the proposed homes within the
scheme
sustainability features are an important
factor here also
the proposed new housing scheme to take
advantage of the latest technology
which will be the most appropriate for
each site the main determinant being
whether the site
is new build or refurbishment where
possible again
air source heat pumps will be used as
the main source of heating
these will connect on the floor heating
system if this is not possible
in a refurbished location then it will
feed a radiator system
ventilation will be provided by
mechanical ventilation and heat recovery
systems
solar panels will be provided at roof
level in discrete locations
subject to any building and planning
constraints
in this way we'll provide local
electrical generation
and reduce overall consumption from the
grid
in addition electric vehicle charging
points will also be
will be provided on every residential
site
as peter set out the proposals will also
preserve and enhance the setting of the
listed windmill
now popular wedding venue and preserve
the setting of the listed barrington's
building
on the civic suite site
turning to social value
social value has been a key theme since
the early part of this program
and that's about how we can secure wider
social economic and environmental
benefits through the programme
the council set out the importance of
this when developing the early phase of
the program
and gb partnerships have responded
positively
when we talk about social value what we
mean is things
including skills and employment the
program will create apprenticeships and
work placements
we're looking at the local supply chain
and sourcing locally
we'll also set out how we can protect
the environment with sustainable
solutions with energy efficient
developments
as touched on um just previously and
finally and perhaps most rewarding of
all it's about engaging with local
schools
social enterprises and local groups to
ensure they all have the opportunity to
engage in the program
my final slide just setting out time
scales and next steps
as andrew has set out and councilwoodson
this is a pre-application
engagement process and we want it to be
meaningful
and we encourage your feedback either
this evening to the q a function
or by the link on the screen to the
voyage website
engagement survey is now live and runs
for an extended period
until the 11th of april and we welcome
your views by that website
as i said council woodson and andrew
both mentioned how important engagement
is this program at this early
pre-application stage and we do welcome
your feedback
thank you thank you matt um for that
very
interesting presentation i hope that um
all those listening to this webinar have
found the presentations very
enlightening
indeed they may well already have
covered some
or many or all of the issues that you
have been unsure of to date
specific details but we are now without
further delay going to move on to the
question and answer session
some questions i will read out on behalf
of the person who has raised them
whilst others will be raised by the
person themselves
live this is a very important part of
this webinar
and i think i hope you can sense already
just how
serious both rochelle district council
and gb
partnership and their colleagues are
taking public involvement
public questions in the whole of this
process and that's going to continue
so i'm going to start off with question
one
if i can please which is a question on
traffic now just
for your information we've tried to be
representative in a number of different
questions and different topics
we didn't want to have questions only on
one or two topics so we are trying to
cover
a vast range of the whole gambit of the
um
operation so we're starting off with
question number one this is i'm reading
this out on behalf of lee street and
who posed a question and it says there
is too much development
already in rochford and the roads can't
cope as it is
without you building loads more houses
and i'd like please to
um welcome for the first time this
evening to answer this on behalf of
gb partnerships george farley george
please
and thanks mike um yes if i can uh
firstly i think it's just worth um
thanking lee and everyone else that has
taken the time to send in a question
because they are valuable to us um
if i can answer it by just clarifying
that
in in rochford we're looking to build
around 36
units across three different sites each
with their own parking bay
and in rayleigh this number uh as peter
illustrated
earlier will be closer to 57
across the two sites that we heard about
um and and just noting that both
both of those numbers are all subject to
review
and this evening's discussion in fact is
all a part of that review
um so that you can see these are not
actually large-scale um developments
and i would also like to point out that
these are town center developments
and so the need for parking bays reduces
as people will
use public transport they will walk um
or cycle in these more sustainable
locations
so we will also be providing secure
cycle storage for all the homeowners
luke peter touched on that as well um
and finally i'd just highlight that a
traffic impact assessment will be
undertaken
as part of the planning process for
every single location
thank you thank you george we're now
going to move on
to question number two please which
specifically relates to parking i would
like to welcome shirley page
who i think hopefully technology's
fingers crossed will be uh here to um
ask her a question herself
uh yes i'm here thank you very much um
your plan highlights
that 39 car parking spaces will be lost
across the mill and market car parks
with the hundreds of new houses
currently being built in rayleigh
we will need more spaces not fewer so
why are you building over them
you also state that for residents of the
new builds there will be at least
one car space per home a three-bedroom
property
is likely to have more than one car the
32 properties of the meal development
together with the 25 at the civic suite
development
will equate to a potentially another 150
to 200 residents in the town centre
located next to or within public car
parks
how do you propose to prevent the new
build residents
taking up even more of the depleted car
parking spaces
jolie thank you for that uh question and
i'd like please to ask panelist matt
harwood white
to answer that please matt thank you
thank you mike
hello shirley thank you for that
question um it's uh
it's probably one of the quite one of
the themes we've received um
the most queries on parking as we expect
um we do
recognize it's a key issue and we have
received great deal feedback on it so
thank you for the question
um as we've set out um but to give a bit
more detail to it the proposals
at the milani events center site do mean
a net loss of 21
public car parking spaces uh that's
compared to what's currently provided
at the bellingham lane and mill car
parks
but that does mean that a hundred public
car parking spaces
would remain available at those car
parks in total
the proposals at the civic suite site
would result in a net loss of 18 spaces
um from the market's car park
uh all the proposed um residential
development as peter set out would have
their own
residence car parking in line with
current planning policy
and the proposals also include secure
bike
storage i'd also say um throughout
the whole procurement process which
angela touched on we were very clear
as were members that the erosion of
public car parking could only begin to
be justified if it if it added value to
the overall proposal
we don't just mean by any value for
money but also aesthetic value so is
peter set out
in terms of the setting of the windmill
creating those open spaces
and better framing better use of the
windmill and the space around it
um shirley and through mike i hope that
goes some way to answer that question
which
as i said we have received a great deal
of feedback on thank you
thank you very much indeed moving on to
question
number three relates to uh raley's tower
windmill
and we have colin page who wants to ask
the question please
college good evening how can the council
propose a huge three and four story
housing complex
in the middle of a car park and in the
only culturally
significant area in the whole town
it blocks views of the windmill and
cannot possibly enhance the area
colin thanks for your question and i'd
like to pass this one over please to
peter
to give her an answer peter
thanks mike and yeah thank you colin for
your question um
we as hopefully what came across in my
presentation we do fully understand the
historic and sensitive nature of the
mill site
um as part of our initial appraisal
of the site and its surroundings we feel
that the heights of the proposals are
conducive with
the existing adjacent development at
home regal house
but also historically the massing of
buildings on the site
that were um obviously the the cinema
that was there before ham regal's
house and the uh industrial buildings
that were next to the mill
um up until the late 90s um in addition
um the the eaves height of the proposals
um
are comparable in height to the existing
mill arts center
um clearly the heights and messing are
being tested as part of
this dialogue and and this engagement
process but also
um through a dialogue with um
the conservation officers and and local
planning officers as well as part of a
ongoing pre-application discussion
um in terms of views uh
that the proposals have been developed
to frame the views of the mill
um from the key points of arrival at the
site um
those being from the entrance onto the
site from bellingham lane to the south
but also retaining views of the mill
there's important views from the church
as you come along
the road in between the existing houses
so
the development has been very much kept
away from those areas to
to retain those key views across across
the town
thank you peter if we could now move on
please to question number four
uh which is relating to the mount
this is one from derrick price
good evening mike um my concern
my uh interest is will the the current
entrance to the amounts be changed
as in um the slope from the car park
down into the the in the outer valley
peter i think this is another one for
you please
yes i can pick that up mike thank you
derek um
so the the current access to to rayleigh
mount will be retained
um in its current position uh in fact
the proposals to the site
uh look to improve the approach and the
footpath to the mount by
by widening the entrance and making it
more visible from bellingham lane
at the moment it feels somewhat quite
sort of recessive and and diminutive
when approaching the site from
bellingham lane and we want to celebrate
that
um uh with with us a stronger visibility
from the entrance to the site
um in addition we we won't be closing or
causing any closure of entrance to the
mount during construction so that will
be
um maintained um throughout the project
and
for safe access to and from the mount
um in addition we we also recognize the
potential adverse impact to wildlife
that a project like this might
might have and as such we've employed a
qualified ecologist onto the team
to advise on measures that we need to be
taking now
um and certainly before and and during
and after
the construction process i hope that
goes
some way to uh to allowing your concerns
peter sorry derek and does that deal
with your question yes it does thank you
mike
i don't know thank you it's important
that we do have a fair exchange
views can i just make a mention please
those people who know me by the way know
that i'm not very technical
and some of this technology is way ahead
of me and beyond me but i i think i can
just mention just
yourself during this presentation
colleagues who are feverishly working
away in the background and don't want to
be filmed
have already answered and responded to
50
questions that have been raised during
the meeting so you can see that even if
your question is not raised
live during the meeting all of the
questions and all of the answers and
responses and details
will be available on the rocha district
council website
so i now want to move on to question
five please
which relates to heritage um this is a
question
from anne jolly and i'll pass over to
anne i hope you can hear me anne
for your question thank you yes
my question relates to the new
environment
for rayleigh's historic grade 2 listed
windmill
as you say this is a conservation area
i have walked around the area with your
site plans
and the new buildings including the
three-story housing
are far closer to the windmill than the
existing mill hall
the area will lose its current open
ambience
and will look as if the mill has been
parachuted into a housing estate
raily christmas cars and calendars have
featured pictures of the mill in the
snow
and through the cherry blossom these
iconic views
will be lost forever is there any way
you can adjust the layout
to avoid this very sad outcome
thank you anne i'll pass this once again
you're very popular at the moment peter
i'll pass this over to to peter to deal
with please thank you
thanks mike uh and and thank you ann um
and thank you for taking the time to
um to really look at the proposals and
and visit the site
um you're right that the current outline
proposals do include
new build development that is closer to
the windmill than the current footprint
of the mill arts
and events center but the new build
is further away from the mill than the
current car parking area that that sits
and the recycling bins that sit to the
rear of the
mill building um so whilst we're we're
putting built form
um closer to the building we feel that
with the other sort of landscaping
proposals and remastered planning of of
of the site we are improving the setting
of of the mill
um i think the conservation area
appraisal at the moment does um
does state that car parking is is
generally harmful
in terms of the setting of the mill and
other heritage assets
um in the town um
as i've explained that in my
presentation the new build development
has been located
to create this strong visual access um
axis sorry between the mill and and the
entrance to the site from bellingham
lane
and retain those views from from the
church through the buildings at the
north end of bellingham lane
um and the landscape gardens to the rear
of the mill will be retained
uh in full um so hopefully those
those picturesque views um can still be
um
retained can still be achieved with the
landscaping to the rear of the mill and
with
with new public space to the front of
the mill
[Music]
whilst this obviously some existing
trees will need to be removed to
accommodate the new development
these will be replaced with um with a
selection of species and
and location of new trees that are being
carefully considered to enhance the
setting of the mill
um but i i do appreciate appreciate your
comments and as we've said at the
beginning this is
an opportunity to um to receive your
your thoughts and concerns and these
will be taken forward as we develop the
design game going forward so thank you
man
peter thank you and thank you anne for
that question as well
we're moving on now to question number
six please
uh and this is a question from joe gooch
who
um asks about kobe pandemic and
engagement
so over to you joe for your question oh
yeah can you hear me
can you hear me i certainly can yes yep
cool
uh yeah i just first of all just want to
say i hope we are going to mention the
mill hall at some point because we seem
to be avoiding that
so far but my question is um why are
rochford district council
not giving the raelian wider community
the courtesy
of waiting until we are out of a
pandemic before moving ahead with this
engagement and these plans so that a
proper consultation
engagement and debate can take place
with community
in-person public meetings and where
those who are not on the internet
can have their say what's the rush
uh matt can you answer this one please
of course mike thank you evening joe
nice to see you and thanks for the
question
um again another key area um
yeah certainly we need to that is uh
needs to be raised and discussed um
it's i think i'd say from the outset the
restrictions the code of restrictions
have presented real challenges um
engagement regarding these proposals
and we certainly recognize that um
we have worked hard uh to overcome this
uh and we are offering multiple channels
of engagement
um to ensure we already can as much as
we can
to reach out to residents uh on these
proposals
um we have placed detailed articles in
the echo
one for the rayleigh sites and one for
the rochester site
that included key information and facts
regarding the proposals
and also some of the images peter's
walked us through this evening
we also created a stakeholder focus uh
groups
um to ensure that we can change
engage with the key stakeholders uh and
local user groups
um that use their facilities and that
was to listen to their feedback on the
proposals and better understand
how they operate currently uh as groups
um we've touched on the voyage website
but i'll raise that again in terms of
how we're using that we'll continue to
use that to update
all the key information on the program
such as the background of the program
that angela
touched on on her introduction also the
time scales and the details of the
proposals themselves as they as they
develop
that has a function to raise questions
and complete a survey
we've had an awful lot of traffic
through that which is really useful and
welcome i'll certainly
encourage everyone to if they're not
already this evening to
log onto that website and so give us
their feedback on them
on that website there's a free text
space within that website within the
question there so you're not constrained
in terms of feedback you give us and as
i say we certainly welcome all of that
although we do recognize that not
everyone has instant access
um of course or simply would prefer a
different method
to communicate with us so for that
reason we uh
we of course have the option still to
write to us at the main council offices
and we'll continue to promote that as an
option to contact us
and we've also launched this week a
telephone call back
service so in fact that's an opportunity
for residents to
speak to a senior member of the team
including myself
and angela hutchins who you heard from
earlier to pose any questions
and to provide feedback so yes
absolutely this has
um given us uh presented challenges but
um i think we've done and we'll continue
as much as we can to engage as fully as
we can
um to listen to residents feedback and
to make sure
we build into the program consider it
and take it forward um hopefully joe
that goes some way to um
to answer that question through you mike
well
not really i mean it doesn't explain why
you're still pushing ahead with it
when we're still in a pandemic we should
be waiting so we can have proper
meetings in town halls
and trouble is people that's a lot of
people still don't even know this
information
you know you say oh you can go on the
website and you can book a telephone
call i mean if you haven't got the
internet that's no good
you should be doing leaflets to every
property in the area so people are fully
aware
and they should be in person community
meetings in town halls
after the pandemic it shouldn't be being
rushed through when people's
main focus is on their own survival of
themselves and their families both
literally and financially
matt can you just give a brief response
to that please
did you hear that matt sorry
sorry i just lost connection mike
apologies i'm back now but the last 30
seconds apology joe i lost the last 30
seconds then
no i said you should be you should be
sending leaflets to every address
in in raley in the surrounding area
because it's a community center which
which we all use i mean
you know there's it's been a lot of
unsubstantiated claims about it being
underused and under capacity which is
ridiculous as you know as well as i do
it's booked on a per room
cost basis not capacity basis and it's
used every single day of the year but
that aside
that's a reason why everyone in rayleigh
should be getting contacted via leaflet
and why there should be public town hall
meetings in person
after the pandemic and it should be
getting rushed through now
matt brief response please yeah of
course i may um
i believe uh might through you mike
angela hutchins like to come at this
point but um just before she does
um joe i'm completely understand those
concerns on those issues
um just the flag of course andrew did an
introduction no decision has been taken
yet so we are still engagement stage
this will still go to members in october
for a final decision we are still the
engagement stage
yes we've considered um leafleting and
we have a campaign of that when the
restrictions allow us to
but yeah i completely hear what you're
saying joe in terms of that point um
matt thank you
thank you man i think manchester united
i was gonna say can i pass over to
angela please to give her
a further response angela thank you mike
just really too
i think matt beat me to the punch there
essentially um
this project has been running um since
uh
2019 and and indeed in in the early
months
at the last month of 2018 so it's been a
project that's been
ongoing for a long time we always knew
that we were going to
start to engage with the community as
soon as we had proposals at a state
that was sufficiently detailed to be
able to bring them forward and that time
is now but the reason we're bringing it
forward now
is as um matt said we've got
still got plenty of time for that
engagement process to take place we
haven't yet got a planning um
application and we haven't yet got a
decision we're not planning to take any
decisions
until the back end of this year as soon
as lockdown is lifted
at the end of this month we'll look
again at our communication engagement
strategy
we've already had some feedback from
people who would like to participate in
the stakeholder forum
and from other groups of interested
stakeholders that we need to contact
directly
and then we'll be able to engage with
them in a much more fulsome way than we
can
as you know the government roadmap
prevents indoor meetings at present
and so it's just not possible under
current restrictions to to have
um town hall meetings well that's why
you should wait until afterwards
but that doesn't mean the business stops
and that's you know and
the council continues to deliver
business through digital
restrictions change following the prime
minister's roadmap thank you mike
no thank you um that's a fairly
comprehensive answer you've had from two
of the panelists joe
i'm sure that if you want to continue
that conversation they'll be more than
happy if you do so
by the the the website and the questions
uh that ever you want
you did mention at the beginning of your
um question joe
that um you're disappointed and
surprised i think that
as to why the mill hole has not
mentioned
so if we move on to question number
seven i can solve that for you straight
away
um with question number seven please
which relates to design
will the new development of the mill
hall this is a question from dawn
wood please good evening
and will the new redevelopment of the
mill hall include the green
out the front to be developed as it's
the area that the whole israeli
residents use on a constant basis
to meet families especially in the kobe
situation at the moment
uh peter perhaps this is another one
that you can answer please
to give details of how the public can
relax in the various
aspects of the whole of development
whether it's the sensory garden
whether it's uh by the where the new
holocaust memorial is going to be
so perhaps i can pass over to you please
peter
yes certainly thanks mike and and thank
you dawn
um so i i can say that the green space
in front of the mill
is is not going to be built on it's not
going to be developed in terms of
new buildings um but the proposal is to
look at its re-landscaping
um to respond to new vehicular access
and circulation
into the site from ellingham lane um and
that re landscaping will
look to retain the existing trees that
are on that area um
as much as we can we possibly can
the proposals allow for the uh careful
and sympathetic
relocation of the beacon and the
memorial um
at the moment with we're proposing to
relocate those
to the north part of the site either
into the existing sensory garden that's
beyond the mill um or certainly to the
part of the public realm that's being
created around the mill
um and that will be away from uh the
sort of immediate traffic
um along bellingham lane and the current
sort of
vehicular routes around the existing
green space
and will ensure that they're fully
accessible to the public at all times
um so we hope that the new location will
better reflect the importance of these
civic memorials um and be safer for
residents to access
um but we we of course welcome you know
one of the reasons
for for these these sessions is is to
welcome feedback on on options
um and any ideas and thoughts and for
any precise locations
we've also completed a full tree survey
um
taking into account uh the current
condition and expected
remaining lifespan of the trees on site
and the trees with the most value are
those towards the entrance um
onto the into the car park and um near
the memorials
so um whilst some trees across the site
have got
structural defects um due to
overcrowding um
and some have sort of maximum numbers of
years remaining in terms of their
natural lifespan
um as the the scheme develops in more
detail with input from
landscape architects and
arboriculturalists we will be developing
a replanting
scheme with suitable trees across the
site
um so hopefully that that sort of
responds as i say
there's certainly no we we think from an
urban design and architectural master
planning perspective that
arrivals point off bellingham lane onto
the site is really important
um and certainly any sort of infilling
of that with with built form onto
bellingham lane would be
um wouldn't be the right solution in any
way um
it's about inviting and encouraging
people into the site towards the
entrance to the mount or
up towards the mill that we want to
achieve with the design proposals
okay thank you thank you peter
as i've said we are trying to cover
during this question and answer
session as many diverse and varied
questions from the attendees and those
who submitted questions if we possibly
can
from the whole range of the the whole
project and i know
um from reading and various papers and
various conversations i've had with
people
one of the big concerns of the whole
project regarding the mill hall
is larger events so i'd like to move on
to question number eight
if i can please and this is a question
from wendy edward so
wendy can i pass over to you please yes
okay thank you very much
and i feel that a few of my question has
been answered
in the presentations earlier but i do
understand the reason for the
development
but my concern is the size of the
accommodation it provides for larger
groups
and organizations i realize that the pro
proposed plan will cater for most of the
groups and eventually use the facilities
already
but i would like to ask you to consider
larger groups who already use the mill
as well as recognizing that there will
be occasions
when a larger venue is required i
believe there will no longer
be anywhere within the rochford district
which would be
able to cater for events of more than
200 people
thank you wendy for that question and i
think this is one that i'd like to pass
over to to matt please um if you can
answer it
certainly mike and evening wendy thank
you for the question um
as you say yes it's probably with
parking probably the one of our top
um queries as we anticipated and so
quite right that we
that we consider it this evening um
in terms of response i think you all
know the melody event centre has been um
the mainstay of
private events um since since 1971
um at that location um but
as i think we've set out the
presentation the building is is showing
its age
compared to other venues in the locality
um and the analysis does show that was
underused for its size
pre-coded and pre-pre-pandemic
um that's not to say that it isn't
booked frequently um
but the rooms were often too big and
unsuitable for their users due to the
running costs
um so which in effect meant that the
real charges would not have been
competitive for those booking the space
um so the proposed scheme and as we've
said this evening
i stress the word propose these are just
proposals at this point
is to replace existing building with a
brand new community center
which will be owned and operated by the
by the council
um in terms of the size um the size and
design
that was arrived upon following uh
analysis of the room requirements as the
most popular uses of those rooms
so that means that although the new
center will be smaller um
it's a total um gia so gross internal
area of about 437 square meters on the
current proposals
um so small than existing buildings
still big enough for over
approximately 95 percent of the bookings
uh which existing hall accommodated
before the pandemic
so approximately 95 percent for the
remaining of bookings that is
for the main 95 percent of the large
events you refer to wendy
so those uh in excess of 170 people
seated
um there are a number of ways that we
can
uh work with them to ensure they can
continue to be accommodated
we are talking directly with them
through the stakeholder focus groups on
a one-to-one basis
um to ensure that we can find ways
together they can continue to thrive
in rayleigh um so we are talking to them
in detail at those stakeholder forums
uh it's also worth saying that um
because i've said the council would
operate the building
um as a community center rather than a
commercial events hire
if you like um it won't need to be on a
first come first serve basis or a most
lucrative event takes priority
we'll be able to make decisions about
things like hiring fees and charges
so that we can support those local
groups those valued local groups that do
use the facility currently
and and future you know and groups in
the future to come that they've existed
at the moment that would
that would use the site um so
i suppose in closing we do recognize
that we know that those community shows
are popular we want them to continue
um so we all work together um to make
sure that it's economically viable
for them to be operate from the
proposition of community standards
i hope that's a helpful answer wendy
could i just
ask another but how many people can
actually seat
in you know the whole hall what is that
capacity
so 170.
so it's a very question when you said
that the image that peter showed earlier
shows 160 170 seated
theater style and the image peter showed
had space for a staging area as well
okay yeah is it possible to be part of
the stakeholder forum
absolutely we absolutely welcome that i
think i might mention it earlier
absolutely we hold um there are a number
of stakeholder focus groups and forums
we absolutely welcome um other residents
and groups to join those forums
uh my colleague dawn tribe um
partnership team at the council
is on this call tonight working on the
background on the questions
and we'll absolutely collect that and
yeah we'll make sure we get an invite to
that stakeholder
okay thank you very much wendy wendy can
i just mention that i
i'm a member of that stakeholder group
myself and off the top of my head
um i think the next meeting's on the
first of april but as matt said don will
be in touch with you
okay matt can i just ask sort of a half
a supplementary piece because
when his question did mention i believe
there will no longer be anywhere within
the rocha district which will be able to
cater for
large event would you like to just give
just a couple of sentences perhaps on
the freight house and the um
arrangements within the freight house
for holding
large events there as well as in the new
community centre
thank you yeah of course no problem at
all so the proposals
um for um the freight house i'll put
peter on the spot now to see if he's got
any uh
the figures to hand but while i'm
talking um the proposals for that site
are to refurbish uh the existing freight
house
uh we we spent a good hour on this at
the previous webinar
um that's about to refurbish that
facility um
to enable the room to be subdivided also
for smaller groups again
but also for larger groups um to improve
the access to the open space to the rear
of the facility
um angela touched on in terms of
refurbishment that would include
a better acoustic solution it's very
echoey in there for anyone that's used
it
can we and essentially
refurbishing the site for the community
um so
uh it's absolutely category that that
site will be
for the community to use to hire to
enjoy and welcome back after that
proposed refurbishment
yeah okay i i'll speak with somebody
again i'm sure
thank you very much matt thank you for
that
you've just highlighted one of the
aspects of the whole project
is that we have to take all six sites
rather than one site in isolation
i know that understandably uh some
people are more interested in one site
or one aspect of the overall project
but it is the overall whole picture
rather than just one individual
for the whole of the rocha district
council so thanks to wendy for that
question
and we now move on to question number
nine please
uh this one relates to future management
and i believe hopefully we have richard
lamborn uh ready to ask his question
richard actually the
question has changed
sorry is that you richard talking or it
is me talking my question is about the
refurbishment
okay right there has been press comments
on that the mill hall is dire and cannot
be brought up to standard
this has been substantiated by comments
tonight
can this be expanded upon i have stem
reports by ex-employees that routine
maintenance requests
have been declined over a 15-year period
is that true in any event when did it
become
known that the buildings were
unsustainable
and was that information shared with the
council
tax players also what would be the
actual cost
to bring each venue up to an acceptable
standard
richard thank you i'm going to initially
if i can please matt
pass each one over to you but it may be
that angela may also want to
um it's political as well simon watson
should
not comment on this one by all means
richard yes i'm quite happy for that
matt would you like to start of course
mike thank you evening richard thank you
for your question um
it's quite a lengthy answer so i'll work
way through it that's okay and as i say
andrew mayweather coming after us or
indeed
any other member of the panel um so
i think it's in two parts to take the
first part the um
the council has a contract with fusion
lifestyle um who are responsible to
manage the building the leisure
buildings across the district
um so that that does include the mill
arts and event center
um and they are responsible for the
repairs and maintenance of the site
and the capital investment of all the
facilities including the mill
um the council monitors that contract
through
uh through a contract mechanisms through
site visits inspections uh
operational and strategic meetings for
fusion lifestyle
it's of course is a a long it was a long
20-year contract when it was first let
in 2002
and various um leisure
uh organizations have managed the
buildings through those years um
currently through its refusing lifestyle
so hopefully that answers the first part
of the question
um in terms of uh the part of the
question richard talking about
when um when this was first raised and
sort of the process and when it was made
available to taxpayers and the
information
just to give a bit of background
building on um andrew's introduction
the the asset strategy the council's
asset strategy was developed
uh in consultation with members um back
in 2018
and that set the strategy for the vision
and objectives of the council's asset
base
so that strategy identified six key
strategic sites
to be taken for to be taken forward as
part of an asset delivery program
and the mill was identified at that
stage when that came forward
um so the strategy when it's first
written 2018
introduced an asset delivery program
which set out
how the program would consider the
future service
delivering needs of the council and
determine how
those needs and strategic assets should
be developed to
develop the key sites to meet those
strategic assets within the strategy
it set out that the program the asset
delivery program
would validate the scale and nature of
those opportunities available to the
council
um and essentially established through a
high level assessment
the best order of provides
in regards to the strategy that
essentially led to a strategic outline
case which then built into an outline
business case
and that was approved by members in
january 2019 and is available
on our website the program
and as mike mentioned earlier is very
much a program based approach
was based on the premise of regeneration
of all six sites in the program
so four in rockford and two in raleigh
of course of which the mill is one
that was about generating enough value
through all six sites
to upgrade our civic buildings our
office
and community spaces to make the overall
project broadly cost neutral
the reason we took it as a program
approach is because we didn't want any
of the sites to be treated
more preferentially than the other
um so for that reason we didn't treat
them individually because we wanted to
drive out the value of the sites to
cross-subsidize the buildings
the question was there for whether we
could get best value for money across
all those six sites
so moving forward we took professional
advice and we put together an outline
business case
in line with best practice and
government treasury principles
um the analysis in the outline business
case
identified that doing minimum in effect
just backlog maintenance and ongoing
operation of the six sites
was more expensive in the longer term
than regeneration
the outline business case considered the
most likely options to reconfigure all
six sites
and achieve cost neutrality
this wasn't an exhaustive site-by-site
analysis it was a desktop study
of how we could leverage the best value
for money out of each site
while regenerating every single one and
putting in the least amount of
additional cash as possible
with the aim once again of achieving
broad cost neutrality
so with the competitive tendering
process of this program
we asked the market to give us the best
value for money solution for all six
sites
again taken as a program which would
deliver the functionality that we
require in our civic
office and crucially community spaces
no bidder in the competitive attending
process suggested retention and
refurbishment
of the existing middle arts event center
as part of that programme solution
so in other words refurbishment to the
middle arch event center was not the
best value for money option
in the program richard in closing
the on this point elected members at
that point identified
they wanted a new community center for
rayleigh and so prepare to invest
approximately 1.5 million
pounds additional spend in the program
to create that proposed new community
center in the heart of raleigh
mike richard it's it's a lengthy answer
but hopefully that answers
um suitably the question that you posed
this evening richard thank you i don't
think it did
because i've asked you whether
over 15-year period you've declined the
buildings have been deliberately run
down
and now all of a sudden we now have to
replace them
and i find that the you are
saying that the process only started in
199
2019 whereas for a building to
of that size to deteriorate it would
have taken many many years
so the council has deliberately run down
that building
matt do you want to just briefly comment
before we move on and there's any other
panelists want to uh
add anything to what you've already said
as i say simon wooden should reply to
that
mike i don't think i can add much more
other than just to remind
everyone which way the the outline
business case is available on our
website
uh it does set out the um the analysis
we went through
um and as andrew set out an introduction
this process has been going on for some
time
in terms of a strategic outline case an
outline business case
um to essentially come up with the
proposals at this point
as a proposed answer to the questions
posed in that strategy
um proposals at this stage uh will
continue to engage
but no decisions i stress have been
taken at this point thank you so much
thank you richard i'm sure that you want
to continue that conversation outside of
this particular forum
and i'm sure there'll be a number of
opportunities in a number of ways
for you to continue with your your
questions chairman
yes i'm more than happy to uh
acknowledge richard's request and come
in if you wish me to
yes by all means counseling wouldn't if
you want to make a brief statement
please feel free to do so
thank you very much chairman um i think
that's a really interesting point that
richard has raised if i may address you
as richard please
um i i
i probably take issue with the word
deliberately
um because i'm not sure
that that sounds as if there was you
know
uh intent to do it and i don't believe
that has happened
but actually i accept the spirit of your
comment
by saying that uh the building is in a
poor state
if i'm honest with you um and the public
sector
tends not to have a good reputation for
maintaining buildings in terms of its
actual
structure and there are many reasons for
that and i think
uh with the outsourced provider with
fusion
i'm not sure that uh they've maintained
it
to perhaps the desired level um
the trouble is that public bodies when
they talk about raising council tax
uh they always look at other services
and capital investment
in the buildings just to pretty them up
tends not to
be high on the agenda and we can have a
debate another day as to whether that's
right or wrong
i think it's disappointing and i tend to
uh be with you in
in in that view um but i think we've got
three issues here
we've got let's accept a bit of a
rundown over many many years
for whatever reason and i agree with you
uh with the influence that you've got
there
but we've also got to look to the future
in terms of
at the environmental issues uh and part
of the goal of rochefort district
council
is to look forward to the year 2030 when
we have a
wish to make our
council overall carbon neutral that is a
declared intent
because sustainability climate control
environment is now a much bigger issue
on the agenda than it was a few years
ago
so looking back i would accept that that
hasn't been good enough investment
and we are where we are in terms of the
current building looking forward
we can look at the mill hall art center
as it currently is
and say that we probably couldn't spend
well it would cost a huge amount of
money to bring it up to the standard
required
as well as making how much as as well as
making it
environmentally um suitable uh i don't
know the answer
it's it's a blunt answer i don't know
the actual figures i suspect it's
significantly make a
if i could kindly ask you richard uh i'm
sure you
with the permission of the chairman you
can come back at me but um
i don't know the answer that's as simple
as that um by the significant amount of
money i believe
and i probably couldn't even achieve
that the other thing
is that there have been studies done on
buildings of that size
buildings of that size are neither
theatres
in the style of cliffs pavilion and
neither are they community centers
so the adjustment would be very very
difficult so for those three reasons
i believe that what we're proposing is a
much more acceptable solution
chairman thank you uh councillor
i think richard you you've had a fair
crack of the whip there and i'm sure
that you will continue
to raise your questions and your
concerns in a number of forums
um over the uh in the foreseeable future
but i'd like to see
sixth of may is the next one thank you
very much
uh thank you richard we now move on to
question number 10 please
which relates to planning and it's from
tara meldrum
who's asked me to read out the question
as follows
why have people living directly near the
site
not been told about this when applying
for planning permission
we have to ask neighbours for any
reasons why changes shouldn't happen
the view from my property will change
the view of the windmill
and surrounding area was a selling point
for this house
and with flats coming will be an eyesore
also adding to the very
heavy traffic we get on london hill how
can this be allowed so near to two
historic landmarks in our town
the windmill and the mount and perhaps
george you could start off by um
giving a response to that one please
thank you george i
i will do mike and uh thanks for that
and uh thank you to tara another uh
great question thank you um of course it
is essential that the community and
especially
um neighbors um to any potential
development site
are kept informed and that they have the
ability to
comment upon any proposals i think the
key
point here is that los angeles stated
earlier this evening
to data planning application has not
actually been made
we are at what is called the
pre-application stage
and that is precisely why we are
encouraging
feedback from the local community to in
order to inform the designs
ahead of making such an application
um i'd also just like to add that
whether you comment
or not at this stage you will obviously
retain the ability to comment once the
formal application has been
um submitted
i would just say that we do recognize
um clearly the importance of both the
windmill and rayleigh mount to the
to the designs um when we're talking
about um
the the sites of peter illustrated
earlier
and especially the views towards and
from those
um those buildings and as far as
possible
we will be looking to improve those
views um
and and just to conclude i i'd once more
just encourage people on this webinar to
comment still further on the proposals
by going to the voyage website and
making sure we hear them
just just to reiterate that there will
be plenty of opportunity
while this process is ongoing for
further comments observations questions
whatever it may be either pre the
planning application or during the
planning application process
and i can assure you from what i know
that the watching district council of
business
gb partnership everybody are very keen
to get all
views whatever they are to include them
in the decision making
while we're talking about radio mountain
the the heritage by the way moves me on
to
question number 11 if i can about
archaeology
um as it relates to the area and the
conservation area
and it's a question i've been asked uh
for you on behalf of
uh debra mercer will there be any
archaeological excavation time
given to ascertain if there are any
hidden artifacts
buried under the car park
and perhaps george i can put it back to
you please
correct me um so uh
thanks mike and deborah asks a a very
interesting question that i know
will interest many of the local
residents and indeed i would
hazard a guess that the the chairman is
um particularly interested in
in this um this area as well
we do fully appreciate the possibility
of archaeological interest at the mill
site
given its location adjacent to rainy
mountain a scheduled
ancient mod monument and the um grade
two listed
windmill itself um what we have done at
this point is
to have completed an archaeological
desk-based
assessment this is all the sort of
normal process that you would
undertake um we've undertaken that for
the whole of the site
and that then informs our discussions
with the
county archaeologists and other
consultees
on the precise investigations
that will be needed in advance of any
building works
so we don't know the answer yet but we
will find out the answer as to
exactly what is needed before building
work
before building work starts
george thank you very much you're quite
right i do have a particular interest in
this
and i have a number of friends and
colleagues who are members of the
raleigh mounts national trust lady
windmill uh
um even eden i say the regal cinema that
used to be on the side of home regal
house
and the whole area i don't think
anybody's suggesting for one moment that
there's any royal personage
buried under the car park as in
leicester but
we never know and of course it's an
important it's an important part of our
history
that we need to be aware of and take
into account so
thank you very much for that george i'm
now moving on if i can please to
question number 12
as it relates to housing and i've been
asked this on
to ask this on behalf of jill hind and
the question is
how many flats of one bedroom two
bedrooms and three bedrooms
will there be and perhaps peter uh i
think this may have been covered earlier
in the presentation but perhaps i can
ask you just to
give an overview please
of course mike um yes and uh thanks and
jill for the question
um so just to to sort of confirm the
current accommodation that we uh have
achieved with the
outline proposals that were presented
this evening um
at the civic suite site um we have
uh achieved eight one-bedroom apartments
15 two-bedroom apartments and two
three-bedroom apartments
which provides a total of the 25
apartments
at the civic suite at the mill site
we have um 14 one-bedroom apartments
and 11 two-bedroom apartments
and then um we have achieved seven
three-bedroom
houses uh at the mill site so that gives
a current total of 32.
um now clearly we're at at the stage
where we have the outline proposals
um as those develop based on comments
and and
um the engagement this evening and as i
said earlier
other input from stakeholders and
and also through a pre-application
process with the
planning authority um those are
subject to change that the designs will
evolve
um and those numbers may move around um
so certainly nothing is set in stone
but that's the sort of development um
quantum that the
schemes presented this evening have
achieved
thank you peter thank you peter um can i
just just mention please i do have two
questions i want to take from those that
have been asked why this presentation
has been going
on which i shall throw my some of my
fellow
panelists in at the deep end but can i
just mention that as i understand it at
the moment
while this webinar has been going on
there's been a significant number of
questions
asked on the chat line and various other
forms and so far
colleagues have already answered 88
questions from those attending and as i
said just as a reminder
all the questions with all the responses
will shortly be on the rocha district
council voyage partnership website
so you can reflect on this evening's
events the presentations the questions
and the answers as part of the
decision-making process
but i've just got at least two because
i'm conscious of time
but two questions i could ask please one
and i'm afraid i don't have the name of
the person who asked this
but it was from the question and answer
is regarding the loss of trees
a potential loss of trees at both the
civic seats
site and also at the mill but of course
some of the proposals may be for
more trees rather than less trees um i'm
going to throw this in at the deep end
but it's peter could you give a response
please from from your perspective on the
situation regarding trees yes uh thanks
mike um
so uh we've already mentioned uh
obviously that we
have um an arbory culturalist um so a
tree
um specialist on the team um and they
have undertaken
surveys of all the trees at the civic
suite and
at the mill site and those have formed
the basis
of the proposals that we've shared this
evening
in doing that what they have undertaken
is a typical approach to assessing
um trees on a site which is to
categorize those trees into
categories a b and c um
uh where a are the most um important
significant
healthy trees and that have a longevity
ahead of them in terms of lifespan
um that are most definitely worth
keeping um
category b trees um also uh you know we
want to keep
all category trees where we can um in
order to
um preserve those on on both sides
once you get to category c trees those
are ones that are starting to become
compromised either through their life
span
through the health of the tree or any
structural implications often
it's um the the presence of the location
of the tree near existing buildings
um that has an impact on both the the
health of the tree itself but also
damage on other existing buildings
um so what we've done is to look at
where
there may be a beneficial effect on on
the the site
in removing category seed trees um so to
be then more specific
um the civic that's the process we've
undertaken more specifically
at the civic suite um the trees to the
north of the site
that sit um on fronting onto hockley
road all of those trees uh are very
important because they form
a key outlook opposite the church a key
entrance point
as you come down to the town centre and
into the conservation area
all of those trees will be retained none
of those trees are proposed to be
removed
uh as you then turn left and come down
webster's way there are a number of
mature trees to the rear of the listed
building
um i think there are three substantial
mature trees
all of which are to be retained
and that is one of the reasons why our
new build proposal is set further down
webster's way
leaving a substantial area of green
space and retaining those trees
to the rear of the listed building um
there's a further um
larger mature tree that sits adjacent to
the bus shelter along webster's way
um if we can retain that
we are looking to try and retain that
with the design of the building um we do
have to be careful about root protection
zones and canopy areas as well but
um the intention is very much to retain
that and as i mentioned as you then go
around onto bull lane we have a memorial
tree
um at the civic suite which again um not
necessarily because of the tree itself
but because of its associated
um value um it's very important to
to look to keep those uh that tree um
the approach at the mill site um is
similar
um there is going there is some tree
loss at the mill site again we've tried
to
um focus the the impact of trees onto
trees that have been classed as category
c
um i have noted on the chat that uh
there has been a note made about
memorial trees at the mill site as well
and apologies that that wasn't covered
in my presentation um but
uh certainly where there are trees at
the mill that have
again um associated importance because
they
represent you know memorial or have
close association with residents or
community
uh people within the community those
will be those will be looked to be
retained
um you know the master plan is at that
point where it can adapt and evolve
to um to prioritize those important
features of the site that we want to
keep so
so that's where we are are with the
trees as i say it is um
still relatively early days in the
master plan and
where we find out more things about the
site through the event like this evening
then the design can accommodate that so
peter thank you very much indeed i would
if possible please
just like to get one last question in if
i can please
and it really relates to uh possible
changes in boundaries
and uh kevin hallis asked the question
on the question and answer
regarding potential boundary changes and
how appropriate is it for a new council
building in rochford
rather than rayleigh perhaps i could ask
angela
to answer this question please
thank you mike um i think it's worth
saying that
um boundary reviews are always
something uh that um comes and goes
within local government and but they are
entirely out with our control we're not
in in control of the
timetable or the scope and scale of them
um but they are kind of part of our
everyday
business in in so far as we have to deal
with the outputs of that
so i wouldn't necessarily uh rely on
boundary review
as a determining factor for decision
making making but certainly we'll we
will keep
a weather eye on it um i hear
very much and clearly understand that
there's a natural pull towards rayleigh
um but the council's duty of course is
to all of the districts
residents and that's why we took the
program approach
to ensure that all six sites would be
regenerated rather than just singling
out one or two
um and it's worth pointing out i think
that as part of our
outline business case analysis we did
consider
the merits of consolidating all council
activity at the mill site
but our analysis showed that that wasn't
the best value for money
so i think that's probably as much as i
can contribute at this stage mike
lovely thanks angela i'm afraid to say
that not for the first time i've ever
run
my time and i'm afraid that time has
beaten us and i want to start to bring
the meeting to a conclusion please i do
hope that everybody has found it very
interesting
and informative but also it's gone a
long way to answer some of the questions
the queries and the things you didn't
really understand i would like please to
say just a few words
of thanks to all the panelists who've
been working behind the scenes
to paul wilkins and colleagues from
missouri to nikki to dawn and others at
both
rochester district council and gb
partnerships in the background
who've done very much wonderful work in
helping all the arrangements for this
evening's
presentation would just mention that
although we're going to close the
presentation the moment
the webinar will remain open for up to
10 minutes
just in case you've got any further
questions you want to ask but please
remember that the consultation period is
still
ongoing and you still have chances if
you reflect in a day or two
on any other questions that you forgot
to ask or didn't realize or on
reflection
everybody within this project is very
very keen to have you
give you give them your views but i'd
now please like to pass and return to
councillor simon wooten
to say a final few words this evening
councillor wooden
thank you chairman uh a personal thank
you to you for the
excellent way in which you have chaired
this evening's meeting
uh and thank you to every member
of the public who has joined us this
evening
it really is appreciated and i think it
is some irony that
uh most of us if not all of us would
have preferred to have a physical
meeting
the irony is that through the technology
and the times we're in
we probably had far more questions and
the ability to answer far more questions
through technology than we would have
ever had the capability of doing
in a physical meeting so perhaps that
balances out
the uh lack of opportunity to have a
meeting in that way
but look i recognize the strength of
feeling
particularly relating to the mill site
and especially to those with nostalgic
memories
but perhaps happily happy events that
have been held there
some individuals have already been very
vocal
uh in their opposition to the plans some
have been supportive
i fear and it is a factor that when
people leave meetings like this
there may be some frustration that
people feel that questions haven't been
answered fully or satisfactorily and i
actually genuinely apologize for that
because there's been no
intention not to answer questions that
people
have raised but this program is much
more than demolishing
a building i'm afraid that i have to
place on record
my disappointment at some misinformation
which has appeared
mainly on social media channels perhaps
for political expediency
however my job is to responsibly ensure
our community is properly
and accurately informed with the facts
i believe that we are doing that this
engagement is about listening
and getting views and also taking
account of the broader picture
i accept and respect that there may be a
wide range of different and
differing opinions but there has to be
balance it is about modernizing and
updating the council's estate
so that it can support the whole
community now
and well into the 21st century our
current estate fails that need on so
many fronts
on the mill site it is about creating a
truly
community facility attractive to many
more community groups
than the current use within the
existing mill hall it is about a place
where people can socialize
meet in their community groups engage
with the police
meet the council officers in a much
better surrounds than the current civic
suite
have appointments with citizens of vice
be a base to house the raidy rockford
district association of voluntary
service
and the open adult counselling services
for the first time ever the rocha
district
will have purpose-built offices in
rochford
supported with modern technology in
which
all our staff can work efficiently
environmentally we will have sustainable
buildings costing
far less to run and committed to
reducing carbon footprint
and a huge step towards the rockford
district council goal
of being carbon neutral by the year 2030
just not achievable i'm afraid with the
current buildings
there's been a lot of talk about cost
tonight
financially we're talking about a net
cost in total of 1.5
million pounds 1.5 million
based on the proposal we're talking
about tonight
and from the completion of the project
cost avoidance
of between 250 000 to 300 000 pounds per
annum
and that is equivalent to a council tax
saving
of three to four percent each year
before taking account of other costs in
running the council
it will be fully paid for in between
five to six years
and it will generate multi-millions in
our local economy
there is certainly food for thought for
me this evening's meeting
the webinar will be shared and ongoing
feedback continues to be welcomed
via the voyage partnership website or
you can write to us
at voyage partnership at the rochford
district council
south street offices can i thank you all
for attending
have a good rest of your evening thank
you very much
you